[Musik]
diese elegant diese leichtigkeit ich
schaue mir den profit an quick web so da
gibt man hier noch luft nach oben
ein profi kampf das ist auch der junge
dominik weiter und zwar ist er ein profi
in der königsdisziplin des tanzens im
pallett umso erstaunlicher ist dass man
weiß dass dominik weiter an einer
unheilbaren nervenkrankheit leidet und
trotzdem mitglied bei jugend kompanie
bei der wiener staatsoper ist wenn ihr
tanzt ist er vor anderen dann lässt
dominik weiter die welt und all ihre
probleme der letzten jahre
[Musik]
ich lebte von immobilien das projekt man
verliert sich komplett in den versen man
gibt sich der musik und tanz vorkommen
können diesen moment diese hingabe hat
sein leben verändern mit fünf jahren
nach dominik plötzlich unkontrollierte
bewegung und tiergeräusche aus einem
aufgeweckten kind wird ein vom zuckungen
geplagter junge die tics für dominique
und seine mutter admira weiter ein
alptraum
man verspürt sei es dann einen druck das
nächstbeste hand in die höhe oder oder
zu springen
ich habe mit den jahren immer gelernt
wichtig zu unterdrücken nur indem man es
unterdrückt umso mehr war sich der druck
auf und das ist dann wie ein staudamm
der dann aber pflicht im training hat
dominique entdeckt wie ihr diese energie
kanalisieren ticks in tänzerische gesten
verwandeln kann
aber bis dahin durch nieten gehe und der
motor einer odyssee in ihrem buch
erzählt die gebürtige bosnierin von
arztbesuchen bei denen klein dominique
plötzlich symptomfrei waren
schauen sie mich an dann habe auf einmal
vorgespielt werden aufbereitet und an
mal genervt und hat mir auch gesagt
können sie jetzt auf ich glaube wirklich
sie wollen nur irgendein sozialleistung
erkennen weil ihr kind hat mit 7
der befund domenica die nervenerkrankung
tourette syndrom
erleichterung bringt das klavierspiel im
gegensatz zu den psychopharmaka
dann entdeckt admira weiter die sich für
dominik zur krankenpflegerin ausbilden
lässt ein inserat die wiener staatsoper
sucht nachwuchs cancer der
tanzbegeisterte sohn so zur prüfung
die familie ist entsetzlich dass ich ihn
blamieren oder zu einem tanz prüfung
noch denke da haben sich selber gedacht
senkten wanderung zu springen weil wäre
hätte sie das nicht besucht dominique
der von klein auf tänzer werden wollte
wirkt in die akademie der wiener
staatsoper aufgenommen
gekoppelt an die kampfausbildung ist der
unterricht am gymnasium
zuvor war von sonderschule die rede die
krankheit verschweigen beide aus angst
die schwierigsten was eigentlich in der
schule begleitet zusammen aufzupassen
ich hab was fangen lassen und dann aber
schön kurz ausdrucken oder aufs klo zu
gehen und daran einfach alles den körper
durch zu zucken was die ganzen texten
dieser ganze druck dann weg trotz tricks
die tarnung fliegt auf aber die lehrer
alten zu dem tanz hingegen werden die
texte aber ich habe es dann auch langsam
gemerkt so es ist nicht nur
einvernehmlich verwirklichen kann es
sich sogar etwas was ihm helfen könnte
diese tipps vielleicht zu beseitigen
doch permanenter leistungsdruck bringt
sie weiters immer wieder an ihre grenzen
ich wollte ihn sogar zwei mal rausnehmen
aus ballett
ich bin ganz genervt gegangen weil die
ansprüche waren zu hoch ich bin nicht
wie andere misere kind da drinnen
unbedingt haben will muss nicht bald
anziehen
das waren aber dann momente die texte
ganz stark zurückgekommen sind also
moment wenig dazu sagen wenn du damit
aussagen musste damit leben
dominik hat durchgehalten
durfte 2016 den wiener opernball
eröffnen
seid ihr sein druck contex verschwunden
bauen.de nervös vielleicht ein
schnelleres augenzwinkern oder so aber
für mich ist geheilt
es ist für mich ein wunder ist es schwer
zu beschreiben aber ich bin
überglücklich dass das komplexe
bewegungstraining und die
erfolgserlebnisse haben sich offenbar
positiv ausgewirkt
das attestieren ihm ärzte dennoch
dominique sei ein einzelfall
seine geschichte aber kann andere
motivieren zu kämpfen
[Musik]
ein passendes lage zu